foreign
has a wonderful new word to sell his
failing economic agenda
orange is working fineomics is about
building an economy from the middle out
in the bottom up Dynamics is about the
future
right now it's just another way of
saying restore the American dream I
didn't come up with the name
I really did I now claim it but the
president trying to sell Americans on
bidenomics but they're not buying it
most people feel the economy is in
horrible shape as their wallets get
socked by high inflation and soaring
interest rates it's why a whopping 48
percent of Americans say that Joe
Biden's policies are hurting their
family but never mind that his
delusional White House thinks bidenomics
will catch on
here to talk with you about bidenomics
which is the word of the day word of the
week word of the month word of the Year
here at the White House and bidenomics
is rooted in the belief that we grow the
economy when we grow the middle class
that's binomics growing the middle class
in this country that's where our
strength is we try to trickle down we
try top down guess what it didn't reach
regular folks it makes good sense by
Dynamics right it kind of flows off the
tongue really well
and Biden's bad economy will surely be
fodder for Republicans battling for the
2024 nomination Ron DeSantis wasting no
time to hammer by Dynamics
I can tell you what bionomics is Martha
it is everybody pays more for basic
Staples of life people are paying way
more for groceries they're paying way
more for other necessities like
utilities at the end of the day the
average working person knows it's harder
to make ends meet under Joe Biden as
president
okay now 7 out of 10 Americans say that
inflation in the economy of the nation's
top problems 52 percent think the
country's too expensive to live in uh is
going out and touting Biden and
economics bidenomics really the smartest
campaign well it is going to be as Larry
Kudlow says a pocketbook election and he
was on the Fox News rundown this morning
I listened to that and he makes the
point that everybody is feeling which is
Wages have not kept up with inflation so
prices are up even if you've got a raise
you can't keep up so that you feel it
and one of the things that is
interesting about politics over the
years is that in presidential elections
people don't necessarily think for
somebody running for reelection about
what you're going to do for them in the
next four years they remember what it's
been like the past three years and so
people who have struggled with gas
prices food prices everything that they
want to buy is a little bit more
expensive especially younger people
judge when they think about the mortgage
rates and the fact they can't find a
house and then you add on top of those
things just not just cost of living but
your well-being your Pursuit of
Happiness the crime things like that so
that's why you have a huge number of
people that say the country's moving in
the wrong direction I think on this with
biodynamics they had no choice but to go
ahead and embrace it it reminds me of
when Republicans very critically talked
about the health care plan that Obama
wanted to do as Obamacare and that was a
criticism for a long time and then
finally Obama I remember at one of the
events he said and you know what yeah
let's call it Obamacare and then it
became eventually it actually is pretty
popular biodynamics reminds me of
remember we talk about bite inflation
yes it does kind of flow off the tongue
but in a way that makes people reminds
people that the inflation issues are not
necessarily what people he they want
people to think about the chips Act and
the infrastructure bill as if that's
like real day-to-day economics that's
not what people are dealing with on in
their paychecks
all right Jesse consumer goods are up 15
points to five percent real wages have
literally decreased uh I think 26 months
straight so people's salaries are not
holding up so in line with what with
what Dana was just saying I mean how do
they sell this with a straight face
there was a lot of trickle down in the
previous presidency he slashed taxes and
regulations and middle class wages
exploded at the fastest clip in 50 years
five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars for middle class Americans wages
are going down with Joe Biden that's a
fact inflation prices are up that's a
fact just last year the stock market was
down people are not earning money in Joe
Biden's economy that's a fact I don't
care what you call it whatever it is
isn't working and Joe doesn't even know
what biodynamics means this was supposed
to launch his economic message for the
campaign this was Failure to Launch he
gets out there first he has a sleep
machine indentation all over his face
his heart stops when he sleeps so he's
got a mask to a question when his heart
stops is Kamala Harris the vice the
president for a second in the president
again right and that machine is what's
keeping this country alive live and then
he comes out and he confuses Iraq with
Afghanistan fine just don't send Iraq
800 billion dollars then he comes out
and he just babbles and makes no sense
and it's uninspiring and I get it I get
it you're doing the best you can Dana's
right the chips act's not sexy
infrastructure's not sexy the inflation
reduction acts not sexy you're not going
to see a new bridge for 20 years you're
not going to see these chips come out on
your phones for another 10 years you
can't touch it you can't feel it you
can't even smell Joe Biden's policy
agenda and he's going to have to run on
pretty much nothing well you know this
is typical Joe Biden I mean he basically
is saying that as it relates to
inflation he said it was that bad when I
got here when it was 1.6 inflation and
last year was eight I think it's down to
five now I mean can we can we count on
him to tell the truth no no no and I'm
gonna call you Jiro I know
It's a combination of Janine Pirro yes
right
you know what there's nothing like
smushing two words together and treat it
like it's some big policy success right
a word replaces achievement hey Biden
economists put it together wow it's not
even clever like brunch right and like
you know what I call Larry Kudlow I call
him Ludlow it saves so much time it's
Larry Kudlow Ludlow but these are the
same people that think they're clever
when they add gate to an issue or when
they do when they write a piece on
historical first or when they see a
trend and the trend is when two things
happen in a day and they oh we need a
third one and then they go and they look
for it and it might not be like it but
they'll still do the piece so all of
these reporters get so excited that oh
my goodness we have a word we have a
word and like Joe's like well I don't
even know what you're talking about I'm
not even alive but no one's defined by
economics so I will help them Define it
this is what bidenomics is and it's real
bidenomics selling influence for money
to to foreign countries then finding
ways not to pay taxes that's bidenomics
right Hunters should get a Nobel prize
in economics for coming up with this
he's not going to jail he's raking in
millions while never actually doing the
thing that that is by Dynamics and
that's when he I mean he raised the GDP
of our country by raising the GDP of his
family like as long as they put their
money back into the economy I think that
Biden should buy buy American crack not
foreign crack
fell
down Jake rutfeld all right
all right a study by Northwestern Mutual
found that
1.27 million is the magic number
Americans think they need to retire
comfortably and the average person who
responded to this has 89 000. yeah
something that I worry about everybody
worries about this who's young Dana
talks about what's going on with the
interest rates we wanted to buy an
apartment it just doesn't make sense the
amount of interest that we're going to
pay on principle just not worth it for
us now so we're going to pay a highly
inflated rent because we need to stay in
the city for work it's a problem
Millennials are not able to get on the
property ladder which was a Hallmark of
what the American dream was it's an
issue
but Joe Biden has a tremendous economic
record to run on there's a Nifty chart
floating around social media everyone
should check it out the U.S has the
highest post-pandemic growth in the G7
and the lowest inflation so all the
countries We compare ourselves to 13.1
million jobs created so yes all the ones
that were lost during covet came back
and then we're gaining jobs at a faster
clip than we did under the Trump
presidency 800k in manufacturing there
are articles all over talking about the
manufacturing boom We Know unemployment
is below four percent we have 35 000
infrastructure projects before you say
oh you're not going to see a bridge for
20 years or whatever there are
Republican Senators humiliating
themselves on Twitter now talking about
how excited they are that the Broadband
is coming to them three billion dollars
going on Tommy tuberville I think is how
you pronounce it you know says like the
broadband's coming and then Joe Biden
gets to quote retweet him and say see
you at the groundbreaking which is what
he did to Mitch McConnell all John
cornyn's been doing it Nancy Mason Lee
stefanik these are people who voted
against the things that their
constituents are now going to get and
they want to take credit and they don't
deserve it for voting against it 10.5
million new applicants for small
business loans in the last two years
that's the fastest we've seen that that
happened over a two-year period so oh
one of my favorites U.S consumer
confidence talked about that it's at a
17-month high I'm not saying that's the
right traffic I thought you're going to
say 17 here what where from covid oh you
think well but it does matter when you
when you say that he doesn't have stuff
to run on it's just not true I'm not
saying that it's going to turn people
into thinking that this is the most
amazing economic period in their lives
through the American looks at what their
paycheck it's less it can't buy what it
used to buy they can't retire you can't
buy a house stop talking about the jobs
after coven yeah
reality of the jobs yeah well you know
unemployment
he lied he said he created millions of
new jobs when it was the covert jobs
that were coming back he lied about
Afghanistan he said it was a successful
operation enormously successful I mean
Afghanistan has nothing to do oh it has
to do with this guy lying I'm old enough
to remember a Jessica tarloff
complaining about the price of berries
foreign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else